[Music]
in personal stash news oh that's me with
can do but I wouldn't even got it
submitted by avocado season yeah in
Mexico right there always in Cali
oh we girl I'm here too oh yeah oh yeah
big festival every year where when it's
in Santa Barbara and Carpinteria yeah
they have avocado ice cream avocado
cocktail it's like they've all all awful
caught Oh everything
Oh crazy I'm caught on pizza is so good
I don't know they always have these
random won't stop because the taco it's
like they have like an onion festival
and it's like everything's onion isn't
that great and everyone that Garlic
Festival heard of that yes okay that's
like more central California yeah I
wanted to go to that it smells like
garlic when you drive through it does it
really it's like this it's the same town
as the cherries so it's like garlic and
cherries interesting mix everything has
a festival everything jalapeno festival
in Austin oh that's sick as [ __ ] I would
do that that's awesome
everything's got a festival I guess he
knows come up enjoy oh [ __ ] that's what
it's kind of funny than everything but
you can pull all penis on a variety of
things
so it'll taste kind of different it's
not that offensive to me thank you
I disagree I think things like randomly
sometimes simply hide you even go across
I always think about it when I see a
mole I'm like well c'mon police found
four stolen Rolex watches in an
unexpected place vagina Oh different
body cavity dude we're on it up damn
you're on it really was it vaginas DNA
benefit China we vagina is easier than
above although is it really there's more
space it's like ma'am we have a warrant
to search your vagina she's like [ __ ]
that is a legit bag I want to know - I
don't know that
they found four Rolex watch that is how
much she been doing kegels
she stole five actually I got a do more
damage
do the cops found it because like when
you're not turned on like your cervix
like it's tight yeah even putting a
[ __ ] skinny ass tampon in there he's
like yeah yeah you you know but that's
what they do to us at the ob/gyn with
the metal the cold metal that's like a
Rolex that's why the OBGYN should be
like your husband there I'm like yeah
some other guys [ __ ] got his hands in
your [ __ ] your husband's just like let
me check your chart he's like okay dirty
talk tip all right cool you like to be
choked cool l did we can do this oh my
god that's a great [ __ ] skin I'll be
fine
yeah so this took place in Miami in
Florida welcome to Miami
I don't know I'd like welcome that's but
rock that's but rap that is but rap what
kind of giggle was that how's little
jiggy its surprised it's cuz my throat
sore from the Walmart bit from Walmart
commercial bill and I so now when I
laugh it made a weird tone buzina
warrior five months for all we know
sometimes I'm like oh yeah that'll be
honest we just took a break
so everything's gonna be new front row
we used up all of our stock row got it
alright so this woman her name is Dell
Georgia are you sure I think you tell me
what her name is Stella rabbi Duke God
the J might be spike delageteau de la
guerra other vowels in it when it quick
that name is broken but look at her wait
I have it she could've got married my
last name is green she looks like she
might be Cuban her job dude she doesn't
give up that is a rap album cover right
there dude
just just gray and white that [ __ ] and
put a stamp on it with her name you know
gray and white not black and white hey
no gray and white dude grayscale
whatever exactly so she's 29
she met this businessmen name with my
mom is Miss Mann aka Pam okay drug
Rolexes we met at a popular night club
and then they left the nightclub and
they went to a hotel and then after when
the moon was freshen up freshening up
from this sex
that's when delacour do this ladies
called DJ okay DJ so that's when she
left the room with his Crown Royal
whiskey bag that contained five watches
totally to 108 yeah we that that bag is
like velvety it was nice and so she put
a velvety thing up there it's like
that's like almost harder in
like he was just hiding him in his room
in that I should put the bag in there oh
that's like kind of giving me chills
thinking about putting like Kyle bit
putting a watch up there makes it give
these chills no no the velvet like this
chose to though deep down on metal and
all those crevices but metal is easier
to to understand is like smooth and
slick the cotton makes me go oh yes eh
uh yeah but what if each one's like
three Jesus like dries you up right well
like you know when you pull out a tip on
it if it's not fully bloody yet it's
still [ __ ] crying dries you up yeah
like if it's still dry and you pull it
out like the cotton fit it's not good
you feel the paper off of like vitamin C
like it's not coming off very smoothly
it's just kind of sticking I hate that
yeah so she went outside to hail a taxi
but before she could get a the cab
that's when Ramone sorry saw his whiskey
bag in her purse and demanded it back
but then that's when she proceeded to
hit someone in the head with an unknown
object and that bag of [ __ ] probably
so then that's when I moan became all
dazed and he fell to the ground a hotel
employee saw all this take place and
then they called the cops and then the
officers swept the area and that's when
they found her and who by the way she
has a tattoo on her left arm that reads
poor they found her in a nearby alley
hey what do you guys think and like uh
yeah I bet I guess it's got a sec sure
yeah so she was charged with grand theft
resisting an officer with violence
possession of cocaine and battery she
was also charged with criminal mischief
after she pissed off the cops by
urinating on the floor of her holding
cell she was released on a 22 thousand
dollar bond when a two thousand dollar
bond for stealing on her okay
that's pretty good and a watches yes she
only was two grand to get out right does
it say when she decided to start shoving
the vagina
yeah cuz it like was it like one of
those things where she's like wait you
who somebody called the cops and like
yeah the cops were called so yeah you're
[ __ ] and then she's like okay and then
she looks at the bag of woman she's like
how does she make that call her vagina
is probably pretty busted if that's I
can anyone in the prison ask her it's
like the cop interviewing her afterward
and he's like he's like so or watches
off you don't need women's watches or
men's watches yeah good question see it
was because women are smaller yeah it's
a much easier dial much easier dial yeah
they did say that she was charged before
for prostitution town I can't even
imagine shrugging she my vagina other
than a tampon I don't like anything else
any other leg but if you have to choose
to choose hiding something but or vagina
you know that show that was always today
yeah there was one episode about a girl
who killed herself by [ __ ] a carrot
yeah I remember that one so like um the
carrot splintered off and like went into
different parts of her vagina wall into
sharp or something are these real
stories yeah and then they reenact them
wasn't just like Spike TV or some [ __ ]
yeah yeah the carrot splinter off inside
of you
yeah like the pieces of the carrot like
she was like you know it was too sharp
it wasn't really sharp carrot yeah it's
like an icicle that's crazy I thought
it's under 1000 ways to die where this
dude he was eating a lot of coins like
he had this obsession with eating coin
my strange addiction yeah something like
that and it got to the point where his
his stomach couldn't hold weight anymore
yeah and it just his stomach burst
did all the coins just come out like you
like you they drop the flame like the
open arcade machine wasn't that one of
the things like the gold was inside some
guy's belly I just remember Anna let me
remember that one pulled it out the gold
was inside wait we keep saying
leprechaun well no leprechaun was taking
the gold out of someone's stomach
because he was collecting all the
leprechauns a bad guy I feel like I
remember the movie brown Jennifer gonna
wasn't it oh really
I know I can't watch that [ __ ] I never
watched a scary movie yeah it's not
scary I thought when I was like a lady
says to someone that's a [ __ ] [ __ ] me
never watching any scary movies maybe
the 80s are not they're not they're
really funny like Eddie oh no ma'am what
about like Chucky instead that's that's
kind of guys can't do Chucky I was so
scared when my dad really loved Chucky
and leprechaun he would call them both
my boyfriend's yeah and then later
Chucky married a doll named Tiffany oh
he called that he did he totally called
it in Kasey's colic Chucky it's like
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]